hello everyone and welcome to the best
game anish giri has ever seen
uh this might be an exaggeration but it
is a really good game it's from round
five of the
rapid uh and blitz tournament that is
currently being played in paris and it's
between levon aaron and janipanishi
the current challenger to magnus carlsen
uh faces a former 2800 player
in a in a most brutal game uh so without
further ado let's check it out as this
game is really really something else so
nipple with the white pieces
opens with c4 we have knight to f6 by
levon knight to f3
and now e6 we have g3 uh
d5 striking in the center and bishop to
g2 so going for the
neo-catalan setup we have d captures on
c4
and now white reclaims the pawn we have
queen captures an a4 with
check uh knight blocks uh sorry not
knight bishop blocks and now attacks the
queen and queen captures in c4
we have c5 uh going for that uh central
control right away and the knight the e5
now
and this makes it a bit uh problematic
for black to develop if you play some
like knight to c6 we can start
trading here right away captures
captures captures captures and then
double black
spawns here so it could be it could be
good for white
you know once you develop your pieces
get the rook to c1 you're going to have
a lot of pressure here uh
uh towards these pawns so after knights
to e5 we have queen to c8 by lavon
and now comes b3 and b3 is already uh
a rare move queen to d3 is what's
usually played here
uh but b3 as you'll see has its merits
so here at knight to c6
attacking the knight here and now nepo
eliminates uh one of
uh one of lavon's bishops tonight
captures on d7
uh queen captures on d7 and now bishop
to b2
by developing the bishop to this long
diagonal we have bishop to e7
and now nipple castles we rook the c8
so nicely continuing development and now
rook to d1
white wants to continue developing his
queen side but for a moment if the
knight moves the d2 pawn hangs
so you have to defend it first so first
rook to d1 and now there is one game
where knight
to d4 was played but here alone plays
castles and it is now as of move 12 did
we have a completely new game
so let's see how the game continues we
have knight to c3
nepal of course just continues
development and now a6
uh if levon uh wasn't playing in his
usual style he might even play something
like
queen to d4 and try to go for some sort
of a queen trade
uh and then for example if rocate the c1
captures captures and
while this maybe is playable it's
definitely not the kind of chess
level in place so he just keeps the
tension on the board he plays a6 he
wants to play b5 continue expanding on
the queen side
uh kick away nipples queen and then uh
good things might happen so here rook 8
to c1
white finishes development and now b5
so the queen is under attack queen to f4
and now we have h6 we have d3
and now comes rook f to d8 and with this
move black
kinda also finishes his development and
now
queen goes back to d2 so queen to d2 you
want to advance this pawn and you need
additional protection for your for your
pawn here so here
we have queen to a7 and now comes e3 and
here queen to b6 by lavon so
a lot of a lot of maneuvering with the
queen uh you want to get your queen away
from the d
file so queen to e2 and now comes knight
to b4 and okay the knight is quite
annoying here it's attacking the d three
pawn it's attacking the a2 pawn
uh but what it's really doing is uh
re-maneuvering itself to d5 so here
uh nipple kicks it away he plays a3 and
now knight
b to d5 we have traits knight captures
captures and
now d4 and what do you play here uh well
it's a
it's a really uh interesting position
because
black might even consider playing a move
like c4 here this did not happen in the
game in the game uh
levon just shifted the knight back to f6
but c4 is very very interesting
uh problem is even though white is
attacking this pawn three times you
can't really capture because if
if captures captures and captures what's
defending the bishop here
yes the queen but uh if rook characters
and c4 you you're you know
in in a world of pain for example
captures characters you lost a
piece and you you lose the game so
instead after d4 eleven just goes back
knight to f6 and
now comes d captures in c5 with rook
captures on d1
rook captures on d1 and the bishop
captures on c5
and now the position is uh well
very interesting and white basically has
to make a decision whether to capture
this knight or not
so on the plus side you are ruining his
king side on the downside you are giving
away
an incredible piece here this bishop is
just a monster
so maybe if you can do it some other way
maybe you don't want to give it away but
uh
nyepo doesn't find any any better moves
there is uh for example the very
interesting queen to c2
uh because the rook here is undefended
and you are now threatening b4
uh to well attack the bishop so the
bishop will not be able to move uh but
if queen to b8 rook the c1 again now
both
queen and the rook will be attacking the
c8 square we can play this rook to c7
move
and black kind of solves all of his
problems if b4
or bishop to d6 and then you you are out
of the woods
so instead after bishop captures on c5
we have bishop captures on f6 nepo
eliminates this knight we have g
captures and now comes queen to h5
going after this h6 spawn and even
though it seems like you can defend it
with your king you you really can't if
king here then queen captures on f7
and if king the g7 it's not much better
rook d7 just wins the game
it doesn't seem like it wins the game
but after rook to f8
you have this queen to g4 check king to
h7 and now b4
this b4 incredible move uh
just uh you know throughout the entire
game uh there there's no square for this
bishop you can't go here you can't go
here
you can go here but it's not going to do
much good because queen captures an e6
now the queen doesn't cover e6 and also
this spin so you can capture
uh capture here sorry about that uh
somehow i
reverse the reverse this uh
sorry about that uh a few moves
all right uh so after queen page five uh
king to g7 uh cannot be played uh also
because after rook the d7 now attacking
this
spawn rook to f8 now we play this queen
to g for check
and now king the h7 b4 like we've
mentioned
and now uh you will have to play
something like f5
but f5 is again uh it doesn't do all
that much uh good for white because now
you can simply play queen to f4
and now you take away this square from
the bishop as well and now
black is just losing a piece so instead
after queen to h5
levon played bishop captures an a3 if
you can grab this pawn and get away with
it
sure it's a great move but if you can't
uh then it's a problem
and you really can't grab it but there
really is no
no better move uh you you should play
something like bishop to e7 but it's
incredibly
difficult to see why the thing is after
rook the d7 the point of this bishop
being here is that
the rook and queen are not connected now
and you can play this rook the c7 war so
this is the
uh you know the uh the the roda defense
as
they are calling it now online for for
certain certain reasons
uh but after queen to h5 bishop captures
an a3 was played and now
rook to d7 is incredible rook to d7 just
attacks the f7 pawn
so here levon defends it with rook to f8
but now comes a move that
it's very very hard to spot so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this uh incredible idea while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations
if you found this then uh you are much
much stronger than you think you are
because once you
see this you can never unsee it it's
such a such a crazy movie it's the only
move that wins the game
and in this played uh in this position
yep played bishop to e4
and the threat behind bishop to e4 is a
simple one we're just going to play
captures and checkmate so how can black
defend this uh
well truth is uh black cannot defend
this
uh black played f5 here but uh this will
not do
because nepo just played queen captures
on h6 and this is like
what what if what if the bishop is
captured how can you
how can you defend this well uh
capturing the bishop is an easy way out
for white
i will show you a sturdier defense that
also doesn't work but it it kind of
improves black's position a lot for
example you could play queen to c5
ignore this bishop and now we get this
queen g5 check
king to h8 queen to f6 check king to g8
and now bishop back to f3 with the idea
of bishop h5 just going after this f7
pawn
uh there's no way for black to defend it
so black would have to play f5 to keep
an eye on the h5 square
we're just gonna eliminate this spawn
and now we're simply up material and
black's position is
is just terrible so here we might see
bishop to b2 to try and avoid any
checkmate threats the bishop cannot go
back here
but rook to c7 now attack is the queen
and after let's say queen f5 we can
simply trade here and that's it we're
we're simply yeah in a mi we're up upon
but our position is completely winning
here
uh there's not much black can do here so
this is with absolute perfect play
uh how the game might uh you know
uh evolve but in the game after queen
captures on f6
uh levon captured the bishop and now
comes the move that nipple had to see
when he played bishop to e4
and this is one of those moves that like
i said once you see it you can never
unsee it and after i show it to you now
uh you will see it in all of your games
and you will achieve great victories for
the rest of your life
uh here uh nipple played rook to d5
and now now that you see it of course it
all makes sense the pawn cannot capture
because the queen is hanging
and if the pawn doesn't capture this is
checkmate and that's it
there's simply no way no way to play
this but seeing this from the position
where bishop to e4 was played and i'm
pretty sure that nepo saw it
much much uh before that even before
bishop to e4 was on the board
um i mean if if you're about to
challenge magnus cross and for the title
of world champion you have to know such
this is considered a simple idea on
their level
uh but now there's nothing here levon
can just resign the game but he
continues with queen captures an e3
now of course if uh uh well there's not
much you can do here and i know you guys
are wondering but what about f6 it
doesn't help just queen g6 checking your
chat and queen
rook to h5 will be checkmate so in the
game
queen captures an e3 was played but it
doesn't help
nipple happily captures the queen we
have e captures on d5 now levon has a
bishop and the rook for the queen but
uh it's very all very very
discoordinated and the white queen is
simply too powerful
queen g5 check king to h8 we start
grabbing material queen captures on d5
we have f5 defending this pawn but now
the black king is completely
out in the open uh here queen to d4 with
check with king to g8 and now even b4 so
twice this b4 move
causes a lot of problems for black now
there's nothing you can do
to activate this piece bishop to c1 is
played but again it doesn't help queen
to b6 now you're going to eliminate all
of these pawns and then you're going to
advance this pawn to a new queen
so rook to f7 and now queen captures an
a6 with
e3 now trying to do some damage uh but
the just queen to c8
check and it was in this position on
move 38 that uh levon aaron resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
once the king moves we're going to win
the bishop here and that's it let's say
king g7 queen captures here
and there is there is no playing this
it's uh
of course you know it would be pointless
to continue this
so like i said incredible incredible
game and uh
i would be very interested uh in hearing
from nippo at what point
did he find bishop the e4 so it could
have been
uh maybe even in the position where he
was deciding on this
uh it's it's really very hard to say
maybe even at the d
captures on c5 uh because uh from this
point on maybe even
when he played d4 because it's pretty
much forced knight f6 captures captures
captures captures
and now this bishop captures an f6 a g
captures and
now queen to h5 with the preparation of
bishop to e4 so
if you don't see bishop to e7 the
defense that we discussed
this is just crushing so incredible
stuff and
magnus will have his hands full when
when in november finally comes but we'll
we'll see how it goes
as usual do let me know uh what are your
predictions for the match in november in
the uh comment section below
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it lavon definitely hasn't but
uh that's what happens when you face
such a such a
fierce player like yanni ponishi and do
join us in the tournament
today it starts at 8 pm central european
time all the info will be in the
description below
and we're going to have a lot of time
i'm gonna be streaming it to showcase
all of your great games that you guys
will be playing it will be
it will last for some two hours and
hopefully have a
a a a good time so once again i hope you
enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank purna surya
cherikuri
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day